[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round four of the
summer classic here in st. Louis
all draws in Group A except for Massif
Dhirubhai Lee who is now a perfect for
and Oh after a win against Jim abaya
massif has a Kobe on today in what could
be the most important game of the event
Group B had only one decisive game as
well with Sergei Matz anko forcing a
resignation against Bellis we're at the
midway point coverage of round five
starts now twenty international chess
professionals compete in st. Louis as US
chess champs calm presents the first
ever summer chess classic
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to this thing
loose Chess Club studio in the 2018
summer chess classic I am women
grandmaster Katharina Nemcova
and I'm here with international master
Eric Rosen today we have the fifth round
of many games but let's see what are the
results of yesterday's rounds round 4
right we had almost all draws in group
group a with only Wasif terribili with
the decisive game against vernaccia
mabye of he had some excellent opening
preparation and this takes him to 4 out
of 4 if we take a look at the standings
we can see the thief is as perfect so
far with version of Cobian right behind
him three and a half out of four and Sam
7 clear third with three out four and
the results for the Ruby another another
round with almost all draws only
decisive game being Sergey Mont Sanko
defeating Vladimir Bellis and what was
really just a one-sided game yes and
that takes us to standings for Group B
we have no perfect leader here but still
Camille Dragoon is having three out of
four there is no one who is with the
same amount of points but we have a tie
for the second spot where JJ ally
Miranda Alejandra Ramirez Sergey Michiko
and Andres took up in all have two and
half points let's take a look at the
tournament format we do have two groups
group a and Group B 210 player around
robins with the time control of 90
minutes 440 moves plus 30 minutes for
the remainder of the game and of course
the 30 second increments throughout the
game and we also want to know that
players are not allowed to agree on a
draw before moves 30 this takes us to
schedule of this tournament we have all
round starting at 1:00 p.m. Central time
with only the last round starting at
11:00 a.m. and there may be a playoff if
players tie for the first spot that's
right and of course I know we would love
to see a playoff if if the either group
can be determined and Armageddon that
would be an exciting finale so let's
look at the pairings of today around
5:00 we have group a where Daniel
Friedman place against Benjamin Bach
Alexandra
Sam Savion Jeffrey Zhang against euros
Arabic rain ahjumma bias against Peter
Prohaska and we already have a result
for the game Vera Cobian against Vasa
Dora barely they drew and that was our
key matchup Farah Cobian against Asif's
our Bailey the two leaders in Group A
they have a very quick draw and if we
take a look at their board neither
player is there Kings in the center
their game finished just over an hour
into the round if we take a look how the
final position happened it ended in a
very very Josh rook Bishop ending
neither side having anything to play for
I actually took or I actually had a talk
and far after the game and he was
telling me that it's so hard to get an
advantage as white in the groom felled
and it seems like the seefs opening
preparation was was very nice this game
and I'm sure of a series okay to have a
draw although he was perfect until this
time he played a very strong grandmaster
one of the best American Grand Master's
here and having the draw with black is a
good result and now he can rest before
the round tomorrow that's right and now
let's take a look at the pairings for
Group B in round five we have Josh Reed
L against Dean Arisaka sava Robert I
guess are Ian against Tata Abraham Ian
Vladimir ballast against camille dragon
JJ a lemur on D already drawing sir game
on Sanko and Andres Duke open against
Alejandro Ramirez and the key matchup is
Andres - copying against Alejandro
Ramirez both players know each other
from the final four where Andre stuck
open play for the plate for the utrgv
team who won the final four and
Alejandro Ramirez is a slew coach so
let's see what they prepare for today's
game that's right both players have very
interesting creative and an aggressive
styles and I think we have a position
that reflects that if we take a look at
the current position after raka fate
Alejandro is a somewhat rare lion in the
Sicilian perhaps combining both the
taimanov
and a dragon structure and i have to say
i'm i would prefer white in this
position i mean two bishops
safer king on b1 and and perhaps a
potential for a very venomous attack
Eric I have to disappoint you Bishop is
just traded bishop
see seven there is no more oh no more
fish that parrot Bishop to g7 having
been played I think we can expect Queen
take e7 I would still prefer White's
position I mean it seems like all the
focus is on the King side and especially
in situations with opposite side
castling you want the focus to be on the
side or your opponent's king is
currently staying I think that's true
there's also tonight on g4 which is a
perfect spot and it's no defining
looking but also having some threatening
chances well let's see what are the
prices also because players are having
interesting games for so what are they
fighting for right there's a lot of
money on the line a very generous
$22,000 for Group A with a $6,000
first-place prize and the prize fund for
Group B the total of $14,000 and the
first player the winner takes 4,000 home
lots of money on the line and every half
point counts there's a pretty big
differential between some of those
prizes so let's look at the game between
Alexander engage and Sam 7 I thought
alexandra has excellent chances to score
a point that's right and actually that
game is already done the the final
position white is just simply crushing
of two pawns I I don't know if we go
back if light was winning for a while it
seems like just a huge material
advantage we were taking a look at this
game earlier and it seemed like like in
dish was just simply out playing Sam I
think he must be very happy he scored
his first point in this tournament and
maybe a little have him in the studio
it's very possible but let's move on now
to some other games a game that really
jumps out is a battle between Geoffrey
Zhang and euros Arabic should point out
that yarrow has yet to lose a game this
tournament he has all draws so far so
very solid player but if we look at the
position that doesn't seem so solid for
either side I mean not sure what's going
on here I do want to go back a few moves
there's a very interesting idea played
around in this position Bach played a 5
why played a 3d 5 Queen B 3 and then B 6
and it seems line usual that black is
just leaving the night hanging allowing
the very simple politic before but maybe
Geoffrey was perhaps a bit scared to
take the Knights I mean to a file
whenever it
it can be very scary especially when the
knight on e4 is defending the D 2 square
so whenever route gets to a1 it's a it's
a checkmate so I understand that jefra
has some doubts about taking tonight we
should at least look at the line he
didn't end up taking the knight he
played them may be straight forward
Bishop g2 if he were to capture the the
Bates now we should know this is called
a fishing pole trap where sometimes you
leave a piece hanging and if it's taken
it's just it's it's a bit poisonous and
you could be punished in this case the a
file would open up there's already a
mate threat rook a 1 and if white were
to play the natural king b1 I would
guess that black just has a simple rook
a7 preparing the double-up this seems to
be very good for black very good for
black very dangerous for white I
understand why Geoffrey decided not to
take tonight
so let's actually see what happened in
the game he played Bishop g2 leaving
them out on b4 and then the game
progressed it seems like jariabek just
wants to completely open up the Queen
side I mean when you advance pawns and
you try and open up lines it becomes a
lot easier to to attack against the king
and it's interesting because we talked
to him yesterday and he was saying like
I play solid chance every draw it's a
good result and suddenly he is attacking
and playing for a win that's right and
we should note this did come from a
Petrov defense which is known to be
maybe one of the more jaraj boring
openings in chess but we can see
especially with opposites like castling
that it's not a boring game at all let's
go forward D takes d5 b takes e5 trade
occured on e4 except black black instead
of taking on e4 played the the counter
attacking c4 lunging forward with the
pawn hitting the Queen on b3 Queen a for
played them black recaptured the bishop
and then rook H e1 brings us to the
final position where I think it's really
hard to judge who stands better here I
mean I do like white setup with with
both rooks in the center and maybe box
Queen not having the the best spot on on
e4 and the question will be maybe at
some moment when there is no knight on
e4 defending the DT square maybe we will
be able to take the knight on before us
white it's actually a good points like
if we can imagine some move perhaps
Queen f3 maybe white could get away with
taking and then if if the rook comes to
a1 the King can escape on d2 white is
perfect pieces rooks are developed
Bishop is on excellent III squares there
is no default breakout so I think this
is fine for white yeah and if we look at
the current position I guess there might
be two problems for black to deal with
and the awkwardness of the Queen being
on the same file as White's truck
perhaps white having the the immediate
threat of Bishop h6 and also maybe white
considering taking the not on b4 so it
seems like yarrow is under some pressure
here
but he does have a 10 minute time
advantage so we'll we will have to keep
an eye on this game so let's move on I
thought it was an interesting game
between Josh Schrader and Fidel and
dinara Soraka Sola George had that one
advantage I believe that's right
and I was looking at this game earlier I
did like Josh's opening preparation he
played a somewhat rare variation in the
nimzo-indian so I do want to show that
myself and Katarina if I'm not mistaken
we're both nimzo-indian players and one
of the issues with playing the
nimzo-indian is black is that white has
so many different lines to choose from
in this position there has to be at
least mm 7 to 8 different moves white
can play between III Queen c2 Bishop g5
Knight f3 a3 f3 and g3 and it's just
hard to be prepared for black against
all these different moves yes so they
never had a difficult situation to
prepare but even if you sometimes know
the line that the player plays he does
not have to repeat it and I think that's
what happened in the game with Josh
because moves 7 playing ace 3 is not the
popular let's get to that position Josh
shows the pretty rare move g3 which has
to be at least a 6 or 7 most popular
move and then go going forward in the
game seems like Josh probably reviewed
this the night before and knew exactly
what he was doing and if we take a look
at this maybe somewhat peculiar a c6
move not the most impressive move
actually if you can go back a little bit
yeah the ACE 3 move I think that's a
rare move usually the continuation here
is to castle uh-huh and then the player
can play something like 96 and after a 3
2 go Bishop e7 I see where black would
be preserving the bishop
I guess Josh wanted to perhaps provoke
the bishop to take on c3 of course
valuing the bishop pair also
strengthening the center yeah and the
tricky part is if you go back with the
Bishop to e7 right now I have 95 which
is a strong preventing de 96
that's very true preventing 96 attacking
c4 also unleashing this monstrous Bishop
on g2 seems like some opening nuances
that Josh was very well familiar with in
this in this line that's always nice to
you know catch your opponent with the
line that she's not prepared or he's not
prepared for exactly not only does it
give you some momentum going forward in
the rest of the game but it can give you
some time advantage too we can see josh
is up about 10 minutes on the clock if
we go forward
I'd like how the game unfolded for
whites even though he's down a pawn
black had these weaknesses on both c4
and c6 92 being a beautiful move hitting
the c4 clung with the night hitting the
c6 clung with the bishop and actually
what happened white did end up winning
both of blacksea pawns Bishop takes c6
played Bishop b5 bishops got traded and
then this very very nice move rook a4
simply attacking the pawn and if we look
at the position black had no way to
defend the pawn and c4 and also we see
the bishop on c1 I mean it is not
developed yet but the future is so
bright like Bishop a3 and the diagonal
a3 f8 is gonna be amazing compared to
the also very good diagonal on h2 to b8
so why can't you super to put the bishop
that's true let's see how the game
progresses because white did win a pawn
and I believe Josh held on to the extra
pawn for the next several moves
positioning out a little bit complicated
black does have some pressure
we should note that when you are down
some down a pawn or some pawns you have
more open files to work with in this
case both the C file and the D file are
half open for black so white is under
pressure here decided to trade the
nights and then rook take a seven going
up another pawn and let's go forward to
the current position Bishop a three
played I'm counting the pawns here and
it seems like White has seven pawns to
five pawns currently up two pawns we
should note that there is one pawn
hanging on c3 but I would have to prefer
the white side in this position white is
also threatening to play maybe d5 at one
moment and have a passed pawn which can
be a very dangerous weapon for the
endgame that's true d5 is a positional
threat but there's also a tactical
thread in the position if we look at
perhaps the natural work takes c3 this
would fail to the very simple Bishop e7
removing the rook from defending the
knight and white would just go up a
piece in this line and that's why dinara
played king f7 defending the Bishop e7
threat right and this brings us to the
current position where black still
hasn't had time to take the C pawn so
white is up to pawns I'm wondering if
Josh has some consolidating move one
thing that pops out immediately is that
the knight is pinned and the F pawn is
pinned
so there's actually nothing defending
upon the e5 I'm curious if Josh can
perhaps continue upon grabbing there is
no one who can recapture a pawn but now
when we look at white pawns b5 c3 there
is so torn apart and not to mention the
triple pawns on the e-file as well so
maybe maybe you have to be careful
grabbing so many pawns it could be it
could be weakening for the white side so
I'm sure Josh Josh will be considering
some options after after what was played
king f7 and in 23 minutes so he can
calculate and decide what is the best
variation that's right and it seems like
a good spot for Josh having the extra
material having time to think I would
have to put my my money on him in this
game so let's move on to the leader of
the tournament become a dragon right in
your bellows who is not having a great
tournament it's playing white against
kamil dragon but he seem to have good
position so let's see if he is still
having a good position now yeah and in
this position I mean the the whole thing
started as some
of relatively symmetrical four nights
opening but if we take a look at the
current position
I mean rook d2 having just been played
very confusing position the pieces are
scattered all over the place they look
very unusually placed on d2 the rook
placed on a3 any thoughts about this
position
oh I'm sorry Catarina is about to leave
we're gonna have an interview coming up
so I'll have to continue talking about
this position on my own let's see if
there's any current moves being played
doesn't look like it Wow
both Kings being somewhat unsafe of
trying to figure out what's going on
here
maybe black has some idea of perhaps
Queen e2 Queen h5 and that with the half
of an h-file it seems like that could
perhaps generate some mating attack I
guess it's a question of whether white
can get some initiative first maybe a
move like pawn to e5 simply simply going
after the f6 pawn and it seems like this
this game can get very sharp very
quickly we should also point out the
time situation black being very low on
time and we should keep in mind dragon
is a tournament leader so if he gets
lower on time he could risk perhaps
losing this game but let's actually
switch gears here and I am joined by
Alexander ingots welcome Alexander thank
you congratulations after a seemingly
very nice game against Sam 7 thank you
very much
so let me find the game here the end of
the game just seems like endgame
technique nothing much to talk about
yeah I think our own move 32 it was kind
of over so I see so let's start from the
beginning of the game I do want to ask
about your opening preparation I've
actually played you before it yeah
that's a Pan Am and and I survived sighs
oh that's right yeah we have a very hard
hard-fought battle but I remember trying
to prepare for you and just having no
clue what to expect given that you
you're very unpredictable you like to
play maybe many creative lines which are
relatively rare so what inspired you to
play Knight c3 on the 3m
I already played it once and I discussed
it with my friend Grandmaster said lock
so it's a variation in order to avoid
crumpled so there are two ways one is
with d5 or to transpose the some kind of
modern or Piltz variation so and also I
think I Runyan played it in the World
Cup tie breaks against mashaallah graph
interesting so yes it's kind of its kind
of modern right now I see yeah so at
what point did you were you prepared
through I was actually quite quickly out
of the book I said after I have
appointed he deviates with Queen b6 I
was unaware of that for some reason
gotcha yeah and then Bishop take a6 seem
very yes rising yes strategically very
very anti positional chess but combined
with the h3 I thought it it was kind of
okay because I have good control over a
5 square so I want to say yeah so it's
hard for him to push he 5 and as I
played in the game I want to go like
Bishop e5 and then control his some of
his next moves yes I don't think I'm
better but the I think at least the
interesting position of the horse and
yeah it seems like if you if you get an
interesting position where you know the
clear plans yeah it can be easier to
play and maybe you provoke mistakes from
the opponent exactly so he wanted to go
with 97 mm-hm and I wanted to go default
to force him to go 97 then after Bishop
f4 I think it's just bad to take one f4
so Bishop g7 was the best move and now I
play 23 also a bit strange because it
looks like I wanted to start the attack
on King sides and then I want to
exchange Queens so it looks quite time
to positional to say the least but so I
think can you explain why would you go
for the Queen shade you want yeah yeah
but but I think he exchanged his Queens
it's it's not that easy for him to find
the like significant plan because I'm
covering all these squares in the center
and I have a bit more space so I wanted
to go maybe h4 h5 or a4 a5 in the future
and I think it's kind of harmonious
position for me I don't claim to have an
advantage but I think a bit easier to
play that's true like
you see potential on all areas of work
for whites but at least that's how I
evaluated it sure so he played b6 and I
think it's normal move and after age
four he took I think there was some
other options but what he played is also
normal and now I didn't quite like this
Bishop e7 I think maybe it was just
easier to go h6 not allow this h5 stuff
because if I go hy kale goji 500 and
slow and I think he's slightly better
there so so I think the easiest way to
play was just a h6 I see yeah the way he
played in the game I was quite
comfortable comfortable so at what point
did you feel like you had a very strong
advantage where he I think after he
played the b5 and allow allowed me with
95 somewhere around there around here it
seemed like a very complex position
giving the given the pawn structure in
the center for both sides but I really
admired the way that you were able to
kind of orchestrate this these maneuvers
with your knight yeah some kind of
attack without Queens and it looks a bit
strange
yeah it goes to show you don't need
Queens on the board to be accurate on it
and now Knight and the disrobe jet is
actually quite an interesting move
because one one of my ideas is to go 96
with Tempe Rock DG one and a knight hf5
and G of Pi with checkmate so that this
is like leaving the square for King to
go to f8 so I think this is quite a
clever maneuver I don't know if it's
correct by engine standards but I
understood his idea of course he wants
to go out of the this mating net can we
just show that example yeah kind of like
some I don't know strange moves but my
idea is to go like 96 and then Knight
hf5
so let's say a sex kind of vit sex
machine did you want with idea yeah and
just to show this male on the board for
the viewer is attacked Knight hf5 taken
this for me yeah so I understood what he
wants to do with troop Jade but now I
get another chance to to create threads
with Nagi - and this is another very
nice exactly so if you goes g5 to not
allow that night into play I just have
nice
with temp in 95 and it looks crushing
for me such a nice square foot yes so
after 97 it played and yeah or another
beautiful light move I didn't see like
the right move for him after an IP fight
to me it looked quite dangerous I don't
know what's the evaluation but it looks
strange yeah and I think it seemed like
all right yes Cruz and I don't know
probably he missed night 97 or something
but mm-hmm
but it's hard position anyway I see well
well nice victory is your first victory
of the tourney yeah I had the rough
start so this is kind of a beginning of
a comeback I hope well they're still
still several rounds to go we asked you
how do you recover from a rough start I
mean it happens to everyone or you
struggle early on you lose a few gains
how do you bounce back well I have no
idea I just try to stay calm as possible
because after two rounds I was
emotionally really pissed off and I just
wanted to regain some confidence by
playing some normal game after after a
while and some strong moves so just to
get in shape I understand you know who
you fight tomorrow yeah Daniels prison
any thoughts on that game not really
actually I just want to enjoy this
moment for a while and in a couple of
hours I'll start thinking about the next
game very nice well I'll let you get
some rest and prepare and best of luck
for the rest of the rounds thank you
very much and with that we're gonna take
a quick commercial break and we'll be
back with more coverage a moment comes
in chess when you need to test yourself
at a different level chess 24 premium
offers the tools that you need to reach
your maximum potential from hundreds of
interactive video lessons to becoming
part of the chess 24 community you can
analyze with friends or coach your
students live you get twenty four by
seven coverage of chest news and events
access to premium analysis and
commentary and the chance to interact
with grandmasters and other top players
and coaches get it bashed from the best
and even challenged them
to a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership there's
a weekend vacation on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone to the 2018 Summer
chest classic an international master
Eric Rosen Eric Rosen joins with
Kettering them than Silva welcome back
Catarina thank you hello everyone so
let's see it again what's happening in
Peter prohaszka's game against who is he
playing yeah we had a somewhat strategic
opening battle and the the current
position is is really crazy but I want
to start a few moves earlier after after
this move Bishop c4 was played black
lady for white played f4 and then maybe
the somewhat unexpected peace sacrifice
from from Peter Bishop take d5 simply
giving up a piece but winning a good
number of pawns
I mean it's an interesting sacrifice but
we can know that black is not forced to
do that at all that's right maybe a
little unnecessary but it does win some
pawns it does open the White King Queen
take e3 check was played King F 1 and
then rook take b3 and I mean I would be
I would be a little bit scared for white
given that like the Queen and the rook
are are infiltrating there's not too
much shelter for the white king on f1
and White's pieces do seem a bit passive
in this position I mean it does look
scary visually but when we look at the
king and the night on e one there is no
way to even check the king so it's
actually true the night ended d3 is
defended so if we protect the second
rank then there is nothing really to
worry about and Rinat played rook c7 to
attack on f7 and going for the
counter-attack now this is a very good
point in that he won is a very strong
defensive piece and perhaps white just
wants to see the season ishutin ear
after rook f8 rook c2 back was played
and this brings us to the current
position where maybe it's not entirely
clear how black continues in this
position and black is three pawns a but
these six is hanging a six is hanging
and the pawn on e4 I mean it is an
advanced pawn but the night is still
stronger than a pawn well that's very
true
but it I guess it's a question can black
make anything immediate happen can he
create any immediate threats and not
give white time to take any of these
these weak pawns I mean can we just go
back before the sacred before the
sacrifice I'm wondering you're wondering
if maybe it was just a desperate attempt
to create something in the position if
we do go back in this position it seemed
like white had a nice positional bind
everything very well defended the pawn
on d5 very solid so white played f4 and
black and just improve his pieces so
let's say Bishop e7 to defend a bone on
a6 then maybe to play Knight b5 move the
rook B to c8 I mean I think black is
doing fine
yeah I do agree it does seem playable
but maybe it would be still a bit more
pleasant for whites the knight could
come alive from e1 perhaps maneuver to
c2 and d4 potentially or even before and
maybe Peter just wanted to make things a
bit spicier and he did it is an
interesting position three pawns for a
piece so let's see how he's gonna handle
that I see he played h5 yeah h5 being
the the most recent move perhaps going
for the the pawn break pawn h4 and
trying to destroy White's King side even
further I am curious so the pawn on h5
can be captured by the Queen what is a
plan after Queen to h5 that's a very
good question at least we are getting
the Queen away from attacking the d6
pawn which i think is more important and
maybe we are distracting it also from
Square D 4 so maybe the I that can be
Queen d4 yeah so bad but maybe it would
keep the initiative here Queen d4
hitting the rook on a1 also allowing the
pawn to lunge forward and if we can
envision the pawn coming to e3 maybe
there would be some more some more hope
for for black to create something
one idea I see in the position after
rook take a six Pont III maybe there's
some potential with with Queen e4 and
then Queen h1 ideas yeah so what if
white does not take the bone on h5 but
maybe play something like rook e to just
kicking off the Queen away wanting to
take the pawn on e4 probably forcing
something like Queen c3 rookie to seems
like a very safe and positional move but
that was not what was played what was
played is a very bold Queen to h5 just
taking the the free pawn and putting the
question to black we should also point
out the time situation Peter very low on
time and positions like this it's black
who has to prove something I'm in black
his down material and if he's not mating
or winning material back he could just
be losing absolutely so black is in a
difficult position now let's go to
tournament B we have a result between
the game
Robert raucous Ariane and Tata Abraham
Ian they both threw Robert is a very
solid Armenian Grandmaster yes all draws
on his record here that's right and we
see the the current position not too
much life just a simple King pawn ending
really no no entry points for either
King and we should also point out Tata
and Robert are our friends off the board
so I'm sure they they they didn't want
to hurt each other's feelings by playing
for win in this game and it seems that
many players are having a draw and kind
of the fifth round is to the breaking
point in the tournament so maybe players
are taking it easy and getting ready for
the last four rounds to fight for for
their best result that's true but one
game that definitely doesn't look like a
draw is a fight between Joffrey doll and
Daenerys audio a cassava when we last
left Josh was up two pawns
he still has a to pawn advantage and it
seems like just a matter of an game
technique until he takes the point home
absolutely - two points up once on each
side extra the bishop is usually better
in open positions this should not make
life difficult for Josh and we see the
last move being played rook to g6 and
then King d7 yeah it just seems like a
matter of endgame technique and we
haven't interviewed Josh yet because he
hasn't won too
games but hopefully we can get him in
the studio a bit later yes he's very
solid I see he has all the raw so far so
let's see if he wins maybe he will come
and join us here but let's see the game
of laghima balance between camel dragon
that seemed a very interesting game
camel was pushing for a win and he's the
leader in this tournament he's he has
everything for him happening so let's
see what's happening here in the game
and we should point out this is a very
key game for the standings
kamil dragon leading group b vladimir
Bellis having a very rough tournament
with with a zero out of four starts if
we take a look at the position it's
incredibly crazy i have no idea what's
going on here but I do see dragons time
is dwindling under five minutes of Larry
Mirabella sitting at a very comfortable
over 25 minutes so I wouldn't be too
happy here as black given the king on g6
and the threat of Queen f6 is looming
yes but I want to go a little bit back
let's go we're white lost the piece or
maybe sacrificed it depends on your
perspective because there was Rudy -
Bishop takes e5 96 and it's very
surprising that white I believe cannot
go like Bishop g3 just to retreat
because black has a very nice idea when
Bishop g3 happens but I can go Queen e2
with the idea of transporting the Queen
to h5 and then for a checkmate on h1
I was actually pointing this out earlier
as well the the half-open h-file being
very strong for black and if the Queen
and the rook can form a battery on the
h-file this could be a deadly mating
attack I'm curious about this line
though because maybe I could defend if
Queen take you six Queen h5 Queen h3 ooh
but then white has a or black has a the
rook t1 move maybe this would be very
strong for black I mean if you move the
King you lose the rook on c1 if you
exchange the rooks Queen take the rook
King H - that was nice rather than
hanging on h3 that'll be game over so
let's go back to the current position
because white did choose to sacrifice a
piece
having played this may be somewhat
peculiar removed 27 leaving the bishop
attacked I'm
sure he had time to calculate this move
seeing after F take key five detaii five
the throughout of Queen f6 is as present
in the position can you'll play rook FA
here and this brings us to the current
position where it seems like at least
for the time being black is defending
the key squares on the Kings side and
let's keep in mind this f2 pawn is
currently attacked and I think we have
the theme today White has three pawns
like s1i defending let's see how the
night is gonna do in this today's games
yeah at least a couple games with this
material balance very sharp games and
very exciting games I'm glad I'm glad
we're the ones watching the games and
not being stressed out by by playing the
games and Blake is only three minutes to
to think about in these positions and
how many gate how many moves does he
have to make they're currently at move
33 so there's seven moves left until
move 40 and I'm sure sure Camille is is
hoping to not blunder over the next
seven moves and I see also that in the
game
Joshua Friedle against dinara cetera
Kesava Josh one another pawn so now he's
through oh so he's still two pawns up
but they are connected this will be
probably a result soon yeah this seems
almost resign oval for black two
connected passed pawns Bishop versus
Knights it's just a matter of endgame
technique and and Josh should take the
point home so let's jump back to the
tournament a maybe what about the game
Geoffrey Zhong again CRO jariabek what
happened there yeah we were taking a
look earlier the position was really
crazy it's still crazy white just
playing rook to e7 attacking the Queen
on b7 it seems like black is trying to
orchestrate some breakthrough on the the
Queen side but maybe it's not so easy
white getting some active play and now
it's a question where should blacks
Queen go there might be some Queen's
Queen trade potential if if black plays
Queen b5 or Queen c6 we should also
point out the game has finished between
Josh medow and Daenerys adieu a cassava
Mike comer they're collecting the score
sheets and taking the results nice win
for Josh very nice went very smooth I
think what just developed pieces
some advantage captured upon and then
got a very good technique to transfer
that into a full point so hopefully we
can get Josh in the studio but for the
time being let's uh let's take a look at
this this Jeffrey Jeffrey Zhang euros
you're a book game a bit closer because
it is a question for black where to move
the Queen
do you play Queen c6 do you play Queen
to be five to maybe play the move Queen
b8 avoiding the Queen trade any thoughts
about this position so there's a
difficult position definitely to sing
about now yarrow has only seven minutes
to go so he's thinking probably queen c6
or queen a six now queenie sings the
night would be hanging so I think it's
probably queen c6 the only move or queen
c8 yeah I mean my first instinct says
queen c8 just hit the bishop and and try
and keep some initiative in the position
and then I mean it would be be pretty
suicidal for a white to take the knight
on on be forgiven that then the a file
would open up and there would be threats
of be take a three so the only issue
gonna be after Queen c8 something like
Bishop d6 yeah Bishop d6 defending the
bishop and attacking the rook trying to
take the initiative back from black and
oh very very interesting position and
I'm not sure if if if black is the one
pushing for a win here a given that
White's pieces are kind of annoying this
rook on e7 the bishop on d6 controlling
a lot of key squares it's a very
difficult situation and we have to know
that players have only yarrow has six
minutes Geoffrey has 12 minutes this is
always a difficult situation for players
to to kind of they're nervous they don't
know what you do and they have to figure
it out because there is a huge
difference on how the game unfolds if
black plays Queen c6 or black plays
Queen c8 that's right and with 13 moves
to go until move for thee you you do
have to identify the moments that the
critical moments where there's decisions
to make where you want to take that
maybe extra minute or two to make the
right decision and then any moments
where you can just play a quick move
with no risk you want to play
those quick moves so you save time for
for the critical moments absolutely I
agree so let's leave them to make the
important decision and let's go maybe to
the game Rena Gemma by F against Peter
Prohaska what is the knight doing
against the three pawns there let me
just find the game yeah we were looking
earlier and we did not seem too
impressed with with the black side given
that there doesn't seem to be too much
fuel for the attack queen g4 was just
played I'm not entirely sure what black
is threatening it seems like white has
everything under control I'm curious if
light can just continue the pawn
grabbing with Queen take a six I think
there's definitely a important choice
another alternative can be rook a c1 I
mean I can wait with taking the pawn on
a six
I can double the rooks and wait what
what bike wants to do here that's right
I mean if you're gonna make any progress
in this position is black you probably
have to get the rook on f8 into the game
but it's just such a passive piece in
the current position and it takes a long
time for the rook to actually activate
and meanwhile it is white smooth white
being up a ton of time on the clock
Peter only having one minute I would be
very happy here
as white that's a very interesting
variation but saying white plays rook a
c1 here black cannot play rook FBA to
develop the route because there is a
main threat rook c8 alright so there is
a checkmate
rook takes c8 rook takes c8 King gate 7
and Queen h5 checkmate yeah keep in mind
the Queen swinging all the way across
the board this is what happens open
positions if you're especially if you
have Queens on the board you have to see
these long-distance moves now we need to
know that we are not using any engines
so there may be some tricky variations
that black can calculate but it's always
difficult for black to to find them out
on the board that's right and if you do
want to look at the games with the
engine you can go to u.s. chess champs
calm and watch the games broadcast live
on chess 24 but it does seem like we
have another result in the ballast
ballast game against Camille dragon
ended in may be a somewhat unexpected
draw
so what happened here we took off I
believe after 96 96
Queeny 7 now watched lost a bishop here
and rook f8 I believe that was the last
move here after Luke if Luke a for
happened and now black I guess decided
to go already for for perpetual and we
saw this other day that that players
when they're being attacked sometimes
they can bail out with perpetual check
in this case it seems like that's
exactly what happened
black decided to sacrifice the Queen and
go for the perpetual with roof take f2 I
wondered a bike had something more there
to do than just to agree on a draw that
is a good question black is up a piece
but given the the tournament situation
I'm sure camille dragon happy to to not
lose this game given the situation he
had earlier and it seemed like it seemed
like he was under pressure given the the
craziness of what was going on also the
time situation so what would happen if I
took the rook on a 4 so wrote a gay for
this is an interesting line I'm
wondering if this could also lead to
some perpetual Lady Queen's 86 King t7
and black is up a rook so white probably
has to continue delivering the chest
looks like there will be a perpetual but
let's see rook at seven Queen takes e5
Queens I kick g5 actually wins the rook
so I don't think white actually can
recapture the rope right so yeah Brooke
a for a very clever move deflecting the
Queen and perhaps prompting black to
just go for go for the drawing lion
interesting so let's move on be if last
came in tournament be Andre stop copying
against Alejandra Ramirez what is
happening there and this is a key
matchup of today both players being
being very fighting players we were
taking a look at the position earlier
and we saw very crazy tactical battle in
this position it seems like the dust is
settled and now we have a very
positional rook endgame
when we look at the material its equal
they have both five points there looks a
little more active on the F file where
the rook on epsilon is a little passive
but is that an Avenue rook and game
that's hard to say yeah I'm actually not
entirely sure which side I would prefer
here I mean it seems like whites for
choice given the the constant pressure
on against f6 pawn but it's not entirely
clear how white actually makes progress
here and meanwhile this rook on a8
trying to perhaps get into the game
maybe there's some ideas of rook a3 also
maybe the ripken transfer over to the C
file and go go for rook c5 so I'm not
entirely sure which side I would
actually prefer interesting but the rope
is there alone and you can never have
help from the rook on f7 but let's see
what will happen there
rook f1 was played which brings us to
the current position and worketh one
doesn't seem like the most exciting move
I'm not entirely sure if White has a
plan behind this maybe it's just a
waiting move to see if if black is
actually trying to go for anything in
this position so let's say black goes
for your idea and price through c8 here
so rook c8 yeah just hitting the pawn on
c3 I would expect maybe the very simple
king b2 and then let's imagine route to
c5 it doesn't seem like black is making
too much progress if I could play rook
t1 oh the rook is hanging on f5 good
points
Wow maybe we should go back because I'm
the d5 pawn can't be defended so maybe
like white is trying just to get back
with the rook from f5 or choosing some
idea with g4 and then pushing the H pawn
g4 maybe a potential idea in the
position but I'm sure Alejandro is
pondering this move rook c8 here and I'm
not entirely sure how white should
actually defend the pawn on c3 maybe it
would be important for for white to
bring the rook back to f3 so the king
isn't actually pressuring it
I say because I can go with a five why
not try g4 so you're saying g4 in this
position rook c8 g4 seems like a risky
move maybe pawn take G 485 h5 King to g7
you want to play h6 but then the pawn on
g4 can be actually pretty dangerous that
was the idea to go 8 6 4 4 is the king
to trade upon and then we can take on f6
but I think the problem is the king
doesn't have to take the pawn the king
can simply return to g6 and this this f6
pawn is going to still be defended
meanwhile the rook on ca could swing
over to win the h6 pawn yeah it seems
maybe a little bit tricky for white to
deal with the the pawn weaknesses in the
position so I oh no it's not playing
rook c8 which is surprising he does not
want to go rook c8 and rook c5 maybe
he's looking for an alternative here
maybe rook e8 and E 4 and rookie 5
something in that sense I mean I still
have to say rook CHS seemed so appealing
and it's it doesn't seem like a critical
moment like black has everything under
control why not at least put the
question to white how to defend the pawn
Andre is in some time pressure below 5
minutes on the clock
and they still have about 7 moves to go
until until move 40 maybe let's go back
to the tournament a we have a game
between Friedman Danielle and bog
Benjamin what is happening there I don't
believe we've looked at this game so far
we have a quite a significant material
imbalance it seems like black has an
extra queen trying to count the pieces
Queen 4 for rook and Knight I mean this
seems just much preferable for black I
thought if we go back to move 21 move 21
after Queen g5 and Knight takes c7
perhaps blacks blacks pieces are a bit
iffy but there are some nice tactical
threats so black played 95
95 very nice moves seizing the
initiative anyone
Knight takes e4 and there are some
tricks like Queen cannot take the bishop
now on d4 because there is neither three
coming now there's a nice trick that
bishop on d4 being defended with tactics
of course queen take d4 losing the Queen
I do like the way Benjamin is playing
he's being very resourceful in the
position and it seemed like blacks
position was a bit shaky but but black
found the the strong counter-attack and
maybe white light was the one who was
even shakier yes I'm surprised he went
rook FD 8 I thought he would go rook 88
with some ideas of maybe Bishop takes F
- that's right now we do have Joshua
doll in the studio I believe we're going
to try and get him interviewed but for
now let's keep moving on to another game
I game that catches my eye is Renacci um
abhaile against Peterborough Houska was
still the material and balance if we
take a look at the position pawn to e3
has been played lunging forward with the
pawn I had mentioned that idea a long
time ago this this maneuver Queenie 4
and Queen h1 maybe this is only thing
that black can hold for in the position
and he had only one minute to figure out
what to do so this is a nice idea to get
to the King because as we said and I
don't even was defending all the squares
around the King so h1 may be the only
way how black and get to attack the King
so white played not queen h5 now maybe
going for Queen f3 and defending the
square that's true I see after Queen h5
Queenie 4 was played immediately and any
thoughts about this position Queenie for
being played what to do here for whites
so wide may think about going with Queen
a free to defend this square on h1 but
then what if e 2 happens because it is a
very tricky move if black plays e 2 here
now the Rick is suddenly attacking the
Queen and there is a check so white has
to solve this issue and probably take
with Queen but now what's happening the
queen is getting here
yes Czech king of to only move now if we
give a check here
it looks quite is still surviving there
is 92 coming up so let's see if I got
something better or if Queen f3 is
simply an easy choice here so we're not
free e - this looks like it's an okay
position so we will go back to this game
after we see what is what y decided to
play but I am joined here in the studio
of it Grandmaster Josh Trudel welcome
and congratulations for today win thank
you so can you tell us what was
happening in the game we were talking
about preparation in the video Penang we
saw a three in somewhat not regular move
in this opening so early yes can you
tell us it's a bit of a tricky move
order because it gives black additional
options but it also gives white
additional options so it's kind of a
nice surprise because I saw she knew her
lines pretty well but sometimes when she
was surprised that was when people had
success against her so I don't normally
play g3 a little bit so do you think she
expected she 300 so it's I played
similar positions like I played lots of
Catalan and stuff like that but this
you're really sacrificing a pawn here so
it's a little bit on the riskier side
for me but sometimes you have to live a
little
so take support yeah a3 the idea is very
tricky so basically if you castle
immediately the main moves 96 and then
fa3 usually the bishop goes back like I
just
show the line and there's lots of theory
you know usually the point is the knight
uses they v square and hits b3 white
plays in the center with ideas like
efore and something like this and again
this is fairly typical but I wanted to
surprise her a little bit so you played
III yeah so I played a three so the idea
now is that if the bishop goes to e7 I
have the option of 95 mm-hmm so that's
what we were analyzing that that's the
tricky part of actually waiting and I
mean playing immediately 3 mmm
yeah so basically if the bishop retreats
I have 95 and that's still quite a
playable line but White has a couple
extra options so in this position black
took and now c5 is the main move trying
to put and that's the drawback of this
move order that you allow c5 96 and
black kids more pressure on the center
97 night I don't really like that much I
actually had some bad experience myself
as black in position similar to this
where you put your net in d7 and it
looks okay but you just can't coordinate
your pieces whatsoever can you just pull
back there was the square highlighted I
have no idea why oh yeah yeah so a
fourth idea is that now if c5 I have
them wave five which is very annoying so
if c5 yeah
a5 and you are blocking tonight the
knife's lost the pawns blocked like
sometimes if takes on d4 you can take
with the night and play a six it's just
at some juncture it's just really
annoying to have that pawn there so she
decided to play c6 so you still can play
a five but you didn't so Oh difference I
would say that here I mean the black has
the option of b5 would be the main
difference I don't
I think a5 looked nice for me I thought
92 looked nice and I thought castles
look nice no honestly I had kind of a
tough choice here I decided castle just
I thought it was simpler around 92 maybe
gives e5 options in some
and black can create some kind of play
but I don't know
so what do you think was the key
position because we we saw that you just
won a corner and with perfect technique
just won the game
ah definitely not perfect technique but
okay I can choose so here I think why
it's just better picture basic stakes if
Bishop goes back it looks very very
pleasant for white but II 5 and I didn't
see anything super clear it's kind of a
slightly annoying idea because I don't
know I don't really want to play d5 and
give 95 I was probably gonna take mmm
cuz then my e2 pawn is very handy
because it controls d3 all the time and
okay white should be certainly better
but I thought Bishop e5 was actually
more accurate because now let's see for
pawn is a huge pain I think you should
be 5 she's milk takes Queen c7 and I
don't know if she mister okay for but
she took a long time so I'm guessing
that this move
caught her by surprise like how weak are
pawns actually yeah we were impressed by
this move for okay for because now we
are attacking the c-4 phone and there's
nothing to protect it
uh indeed I thought here she was just
lost but she found lots of very nice
resources here Queen d7 so I played
Knight takes e4 which looks natural 94
and I thought at first that Queen b3 was
actually easily winning here but she has
an amazing resource which I luckily I
saw Queen d5 so the problem is that now
95 is a threat so Bishop e3 so let's say
I play something normal
so f3 would be 0 d contra well yeah so
rook d12 395 actually rip d1 might be
very clever be ok don't don't let move
that that's too clever for me
well if rip t1 no 96 might be a problem
oh and I DC because there is another pin
yeah I have to be very cautious f3 has
the advantage of that after 96 second 24
mm-hmm Bob so let's go back to the game
so we decided Queen DS I just want to
show this one I'm so so actually cuz it
was quite something Queen d5 Bishop a3
was the plan
but now black has to move a 6 I couldn't
believe it when I saw this move using
this move that is so special in the game
yeah cuz now I at first like I don't
know if I'm more Sarah what's going on
because if rook takes Knight hangs
yeah the night you say yeah I second
why's this night
yeah that's an issue
now black is starting to take here and
make another for correct yep and upon
takes b5 and it takes the rook than pon
takes and I didn't think it was very
good for me so luckily I found a
regrouping I thought that rook FD 8 and
then rook a threat that was a very
important move so we're just possible to
work so here you played okay sweetie
yeah okay I three I think is very strong
here I think she's she's just losing
actually I mean you have you have extra
pawn you have nothing to worry about
yeah we thought that this Bishop will be
very important for the future yeah
bitter corn day three I think is just
very nasty because threatens Bishop e7
and I mean my technique I wouldn't say
was absolutely perfect but I don't think
I ever messed it up so and that's
usually the goal you just don't want to
do anything to that so how do you feel
about this tournament yet all draws yeah
first win so what is your plan for the
rest of the haha I mean you know my goal
was never obviously to draw all my games
it's just sometimes it happens I
actually had some bad positions which I
had to defend in my first couple games
especially the first one I was actually
losing so I just wanted positions I
could play you know where I had an
advantage can at least start from there
and again I think that you were right
that you know preparation played a key
role in this particular game because I
got a very comfortable position time
advantage and I managed to convert that
so if I can you know keep that up and
then you know have good preparation for
other games and then you know not
blunder or do anything too bad hopefully
I can get more wins so we won't keep you
there so long so you can go and prepare
and cook something new for tomorrow so
we wish you all the best for the rest of
the games and I hope you have a good
game
thank you so we'll be back after a short
break this August the best chess players
in the world are coming to st. Louis for
the grand chest tour
st. Louis rapid and Blitzen Sinquefield
Cup tournaments will feature the world's
best right here in st. Louis st. Louis
Chess Club is celebrating its 10th
anniversary and these tournaments will
be a highlight you won't want to miss
for tickets and more information go to
st. Louis chess club org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a crucial situation in this game
Metheny must make a move but what will
it be all eyes are on Matheny make a
move a lot easier if you weren't doing
that right next to me it doesn't bother
me check the st. Louis chess club
celebrating 10 years of promoting
teaching and playing the game of chess
visit the st. Louis chess club and help
celebrate our 10th anniversary
hello everyone we'll come back to do
fifth round of the 2018 summer chess
classic I'm John back with international
master Eric Rosen and women Grandmaster
cut around him Silva so it's good to be
back and we do we do have games still
going on one game that catches my eye
that's probably just about to finish is
a fight between Daniel Friedman and
Benjamin Bach looks like a nice material
advantage for black and if we take a
look at the current position Queen two
just played which seems like a very
simple fork attacking the rook on f1 and
the bishop on e5 do you see any defense
for this move I think there is no
defense what is probably gonna resign
soon and we see that white is already
resigning so Benjamin Bach is winning
this game this is his first win in this
tournament so I think he must be very
happy to be ready for the second half of
the tournament to start with win it's
right not not the best event for Daniel
I don't believe he's won a game he's
drawn a few games but it's a tough field
and there's no easy opponent it's that's
the thing it's very difficult there are
very strong masters from all over the
world so let's maybe see what is
happening in the game arena Juma by F
Peter Prohaska that's right it's one of
the few games still going on in Group A
we can see a looks like Renacci mabye of
at the board peter Prohaska away from
the board
if we take a look at the time situation
they have reached move 40 so each player
gets additional half-hour and the most
recent move rook d1 just played so Peter
is away from the board and it is his
move seems like a bad position for black
given Queens have come off the board I
mean if you want to attack you want to
keep the Queens on board anyone to bring
other pieces but black has was in a very
difficult situation the request ID to f7
and he couldn't find how to improve so
this was his chance
this was his try to to go to an endgame
or just to exchange the Queens and try
to push the pawns
it's true and I think we can probably
expect black to resign pretty soon I
mean the most natural move in this
position is probably roti eight but we
can see that black is very well
or white is very well prepared to meet
these these two connected passed pawns
in the center and I can't imagine there
would be too much difficulty for white
to convert this position and this mean
this would be also the first win for
Rena juma buyer who is not having
greater a man who lost all his game and
only drew to a Benjamin ball that's
right he started the tournament half out
of forest so maybe this win can give him
some momentum going forward to the
future rounds now we should point out we
do have our results between Jeffrey
Zhang and yarrow jariabek the game ended
somewhat somewhat unexpectedly given
that in the final position white is only
up one pawn we should go back and see
how this transpired when we last left
rookie 7 was played attacking the Queen
on b7 and Yara went for the somewhat
direct Queen c6 we were maybe
considering this other alternative Queen
to c8
but Queen c6 allowed the Queen trade and
it looks like the problem for for black
in this position is White's pieces are
simply way more active after rook c7
played the knight is attacked the pawn
is currently hanging after 98 the the
position just seems very depressing for
black and we see what white is doing
wine went rook a seven to exchange the
pieces to even simplify the position
more it's very true when you're up
material endgame it's a classic strategy
just go for simplification make the
position easier to convert seem like
that's what happened and if we get to
the final position Bishop e3 played
seems like yaro didn't want to have
anything more to do with this game I
mean let's look at the knight on e6 the
knight can't go nowhere to be attacking
any pawns and what has a very simple
plan white can just go king c1 king d2
king c3 and they just grab all the
points on the Queen side yeah these
these far advanced pawns for black on
the Queen side are not strong at all
they're very weak and a very very simple
positional plan I wouldn't be surprised
if that King maneuver is also combined
with the very logical rook to d5 and
and rook before and just scoop up the
pawns and this this should be just an
easy conversion for whites so Geoffrey
is very happy to score the next pawn he
won't only the first round that had some
losses a draw yesterday so now he scored
so let's see what are the current
standings for Group A standings for
group a we only have one game pending
that fight between Peter Prohaska and
Renata mabye of the to kind of lower
ends of the tournament so this isn't
going to affect the tournament standings
too much we can see the sea star Bayley
keeping the lead with a very solid draw
today against version a Cobian four and
a half out of five points
very impressive result for fish Eve
given that it's such a strong field so
what are appearing so for tomorrow
who is vez if playing we see Benjamin
Bach against Vasa Dhirubhai Lee so
that's gonna be a very interesting game
peter Prohaska
against vara Kobe on Yoshi Arabic
against Rina Juma by F Sam Savion
against Jeffrey Zhang and Daniel
Friedman against Alexandre engage yeah
definitely some fights to look forward
to tomorrow and we should note that the
games have been exciting so far this
tournament I mean every round has
produced some very interesting and
tactical battles and it's been very fun
for us to watch the games yes I'm very
happy I don't see barren walls here on
and drawers but Perpetual very often I
mean we should point out that one Berlin
wall game was actually a very exciting
game which you don't see too often so
looking forward to the rest of the
tournament we should take a look at the
current standings for for Group B given
that a lot of games are done there's
only one game pending the key matchup of
today actually between alejandro ramirez
and andrey zhuk open we can see Camille
dragon maintaining his lead with a with
a maybe not so solid to draw not so
solid draw today against Vladimir Bellis
but got the job done three and a half
out of five points and we can see many
many players tied for second place JJ
ally mirandy sergei monsanto and josh
mcdowell
all with a nice three out of five points
so let's glance at tomorrow's pairing
for Group B we have Daenerys adora
cassava playing Alejandra
Sergey Martin go playing and race to
copying Camille dragon against JJ Allie
Miranda Tata
Abraham iam against value novellas and
Josh free girls free del playing Robert
agus Ariana and it's only two and a half
hours into the round and all the two
games are still still going we should
take a look at the the fight between
Andres Tecopa and Alejandro Ramirez key
matchup of today if I'm looking at the
the moves it looks like they still have
to move two more moves to go until time
until time gets added they're on move 38
rookie seven just played and both
players with with very much time
dwindling so what if we go back to the
move 33rd to the 33rd move but white
played through get one I think that's
where we left off last time that's right
rook f1 and I was predicting the very
simple rook c8 but it seems like the
black player Alejandro seemed to have a
different plan maybe there's someone
that unexpected Pawnee for so he went
for the idea with point if 24 and maybe
rookie aide and rookie five trying to
trade what's there or take the pawn on
d5 yeah that's a really interesting plan
given the the pawn on e5 was so well
supported and it's not so often that you
just lunge forward without the rook even
being on the eight yet let's see how the
game transpired king b2 was played
perhaps just simply defending the the
pawns on the King side around the Queen
side King g7 played King g7 I don't
quite understand
maybe it's an attempt to sacrifice a F
pawn and not allow or take out six with
check but it seems to leave this pawn on
h5 undefended do you have any
explanation for this King g7 move maybe
he's trying to really force why did you
take on h5 and then be very quick with
playing rook e8 and doing his idea
so let's actually analyze cuz rook e1
was played in the game but I am very
curious if take h5 you're saying that
black would go ahead with this rookie a
move
hmm rook e8 and if the rook just moves
back to f5 this pawn is a passed pawn
supported by the rook but I mean it can
be very easily be blockaded if we
imagine a move like III rook e1 white
would be up a pawn and this pawn on e3
could actually be week rather than
strong if if the king can enter via d3
and the rook can can come to f3 it seems
like white could just very easily scoop
up the pawn so let's say I go here
Ruki 4 and I do want to cut you off
because it looks like the game has
finished apparently a draw was agreed on
maybe we can get one of the players for
an interview just to explain the finale
to this game because the final move
seemed seems to be somewhat confusing
both players walking off there may be
somewhat relieves that there there's no
loser in the game so we have one more
game happening in tournament a so what's
happening between Rena Juma by F and
Peter Prohaska that's right this is the
only game remaining in both groups and
it seems to be very one-sided for white
given that White has orchestrated the
very simple blockade with against the
two Center cos pawns and I mean it looks
like white should be taking this home
it's just a question of some
technicalities if if white can safely
scoop up the pawns and not trade off too
many of the Ring remaining King side
pawns it looks like white must be very
happy with this position just bringing
the King to F 1 e 2 and then freeing the
rope from c2 and attack me the other
pawns and we can see just based on the
player's expression Peter they're just
sitting of his his legs are shaking and
it seems like Renacci avaya of just
walking around maybe can breathe a sigh
of relief given that black did not
succeed with any sort of attack and it
seems like seems like a good shape for
light to be in
so let's look at the final standings for
Group B to see if there was any chance
when we received the last result so yeah
we should note that all the games are
done for Group B very quick day at the
office for a lot of the players Kamil
dragons still leading the pack with
three and a half out of out of five and
now we can see a one two three four five
way tie for second place with JJ ally
mirandy Sergei Monsanto Josh Vidal and
now two more players added to that group
Alejandra Ramirez and andrey zhuk open
with what they're fighting draw today
for an interesting game today games
today for all of the players but many
draws good number of draws sometimes
this is what you see in the middle of a
tournament the players do get tired they
want to conserve energy it is a marathon
tournament given there's nine games one
game every day and every day can be very
energy draining so sometimes you just
want the quick game just to have some
refreshment big way through the
tournament yeah so I would go back to
the last round that's being played I
mean it's part of me
last game between Renaud to my bf Peter
Prohaska Peter just played rogue d5
rocked e5 played and I do want to note
when I was very young I had one private
lesson with I believe he's a
hall-of-famer joel benjamin and one of
the only things I remember from that
lesson is that when you're up a minor
piece in that game you you want to
simplify it but you don't want to trade
off too many pawns if we imagine that
black can somehow trade off the
remaining of White's pawns then maybe
there's some chances for a black to draw
but I really can't imagine that actually
happening in the game it seems like
white can can very easily hold on to the
King the side pawns and I think it's
just going to be a matter of technique
until white takes us home
rook d5 was just played hitting the e5
pawn I wonder if a very simple move can
be played maybe Knight f3 just defend
the pawn pressure d4
prepare the rook to move to e2 yeah I
mean I would be very happy but actually
I should know it's 90 left 3 would be a
terrible move maybe a long day for me
given the the night is currently
defending the rook but you know what
many moves have been played should get
to the current position let's just
actually go back my mistake it was
blacks move in that position rook e1 was
played attacking the knight King f1 and
now this takes us to the current
position with King E - and now it's
blacks move it looks like white might
just be happy to give away the e pawn
and then get the Knight to f3 and then
perhaps try and try and start winning
the the black pawns on d4 and III I do
have to say I am impressed with with the
the number of moves that Black has
played holding on to the 2 Center passed
pawns but it doesn't seem like it's
going to be too much longer if we
imagine some line rook take E 5 and then
Knight to f3 I mean it should just be a
technical win for for whites so we are
getting Sun up with it with an interview
I will have Andres nuke open very soon
but let me let me actually find that
game seemed like a very hard-fought
battle between against on Alejandro
Ramirez and I do have Andre in the
studio hello welcome Andre thanks for
joining us how do you feel after that
game it seemed like a very complex
battle yeah feel like I miss played it
somehow I'm not sure where but for sure
I had some of my small advantage
probably and then it just disappeared
all of a sudden aha can you talk about
the opening I mean it seemed like a
somewhat unusual time on a variation
Alejandro is this something that you
were prepare so that when you have
played several games like this well a
couple I was preparing this line but
actually the night of 696 so I thought
that before the game 36 was
mmm was not so precise but turned out
that in the six is playable absolutely I
see yeah I actually play this variation
yourself as black and I know there's
there's a number of playable moves for
and that you provide in this position
yeah I've even played the move Knight
takes d4 and followed mine 97 so there's
a number of ideas and I know this this
variation especially has been very
trendy at the top levels and the seem
like theory is still developing yes
absolutely so did this move thus
eventual move from black pawn g6 it
seemed yeah that we can surprise me I
didn't expect this move but his idea is
probably to play Nitesh 500 b7 so if I
just play rook 81 he goes not his wife
at least that's what I was afraid of
mm-hm and here cannot go to h4 because
of Bishop e7 I see an aviary Queens a
bit backward also Queen Esther I just
lose the piece yeah thanks 35 or takes
and if I take and then II 5 yeah so
maybe you do have to be as a careful
yeah I need to be careful so a play - 4
just to have knish - at some point if he
plays in at age 5 I said I love this
idea 90 b5 in case he plays Bishop g7 so
that was my idea
I see we should show that for the
viewers Bishop g7 night TV 5 being a
classic tactic in these sort of
situations yeah so but he played I think
h5 ball was a nice move I think
after Bishop g5 I'm not sure why he
didn't play Knight to g7 to be honest I
thought it's not the shuttle h7 was
interesting because if I take 96 mm-hmm
he goes Knight takes d5 which was quite
important because if you yawn I drew 597
a very crazy line okay seven mm-hmm
Queen takes g5 and here I thought I was
a I wasn't so afraid of route k7 because
there have a five
and I'm not sure about evolution but if
he plays Bishop e7 I have 23 in but I
didn't like to be honest I didn't
yes to be honest I didn't like instead
of Bishop e7 Bishop h6 I realized that
maybe I'm blundering something Queen f6
and here just castling o interested I
thought it was kind of yeah exactly and
if I take on on if I play Knight d5
problem we've been helping him because
all of in that yeah or I just tell our
brains of a file which is good for him
so I all wasn't sure what to do here
yeah seems like a very complex line did
you talk with Alejandra Rafa
no actually we didn't have a chance we
were about to I see okay so here he play
Bishop e7 which was also a solid move
but I felt that here after 96 which
happened in the game logged Bishop c6
bouquet she won that was better because
well I have some ideas related to
genetic Bishop f6 and 95 soul was there
it seems like a very thematic release
for the middlegame structures and he
cannot Castle here that is that fault he
couldn't I'm not sure in what reduction
I well I thought that here can play
Bishop f6 and E 5 somewhere rule he goes
yeah 380 85 yeah but then I figured that
there wasn't at you for some 5 first the
gtex e5 and Bishop f6 so maybe like this
it's so yes after Castle Italy fire to
you 5 Bishop e6 interesting and I assume
that I want to tell you 6 exactly so
interesting days I didn't see what he
can do
maybe he can sacrifice an exchange but I
thought what my position would be better
sure also keep liking a fight which
didn't surprise me I sure was expecting
this move so I played there for here he
played a 94 book which is very critical
if he doesn't play in an IG fold and my
position is just much better than I play
a 5 and my Roo ghost if one eye open of
course it sounds like that the knight of
course has been found this 1895 mm-hmm
but he just took bishop defection
it's really ten centuries not sure what
to do here
yeah II d5 and e5 which was very strong
well he couldn't play six of course they
know we'll do taken Luke taxi six
instead of P five
then simply sacrifice f G a G and his
position is falling apart his I thought
well the night on g4 is not doing much
for a moment and it's like Jade I just
picked with the rook on g6 I have
already gained some points three I think
it was seems very close yeah if there
wasn't so I was yeah quite comfortable
with the sign but of course he played e5
immediately f5 and King g7 which was and
here with the problem is that I cannot
even save the bishop so if I play rook
f1 his idea well I yeah if I play rook F
1 I will I didn't like Queen d8 simple
as that interesting he just wants to
trade the bishop and I cannot even go
Bishop c1 because he takes on h4 and so
here yes enjoying like counterpunching
yeah what looked to me what interesting
but I didn't find anything here hmm so
we should know we were not analyzing
with the engine so we were kind of going
off of our own analysis and so if I if I
were to manage them how to play Queen f3
and g3 that and then probably and go
with the bishop this you want somewhere
my position will be better but I'm not
in time because here if I play g3 it was
important that he played rook da fight
otherwise I had very interesting idea
route before and sacrifice in the
exchange
oh it's yeah but it yeah but after rule
d f8 he actually prevents this because
here I cannot even do this so um yeah
it's like an e7 yeah but the critical
line was of course g3 here and here he
he doesn't play Quinte in which case
hold him just like Bishop c1 yeah and my
position looks very pleasant in case I
don't know what he's doing here
yeah but here he can play after g3
Bishop takes g5 that's the problem
HT x g5 + f6 so that I was the crucial
line and I think it's good for him
at least I didn't find anything
interesting it seems like with all the
pawn tension black scheme could be a
little bit exposed but the knight on g4
is so powerful
that's not chopped much it's hard for
you to remove and the 23 doesn't do much
to Venice mm-hmm if I were to manage to
play off six somehow then yeah but here
I didn't like my position I thought that
I could be worse I was trying to ready
to to play it safe and I see it ready
getting yes seems like a lot of these
lines black is just in time too cause
you some problems so yes I played we
should be seven but of course it's
already playing for a drum in g3 yeah
Queen f6 very interesting move
Jetix f5 yeah here of a thing is forced
not there six of course I can play but
but the other work do but it doesn't
change anything
I see so yeah related with this one kit
- mm-hmm everything is forced EMF six
and we weren't quite sure what to make
in this rook ending is is one site
better do you feel like it was dynamic
balance around you're sure that that was
worse I was trying to make a draw of
course but that wasn't so easy
mm-hmm so the way he played was very
interesting so keep it - I mean it work
of one yes before can be tuned before I
do want to ask what were you planning to
play after rook c8 I was just gonna go
against you - King see - yes high five
well there is a couple of options one of
them is just to play before but I don't
never mind I'm sorry
one of them is to play him okay the the
line I calculated was g4 I wanted to
play just for you so he takes her chick
for h5 check from kinkajou six oranges
seven doesn't change more pinkish six
actual he has to play kindred seven who
you want anyway I play route you want
route just seven our route takes us six
English five when I take on this section
I wasn't sure whether he is better or
not to add another possibility for me is
to play just to ignore him after not to
play before instead just wait and make a
way to move like rook up to something
like this and if he takes I played
before the rook is actually stuff yeah
he doesn't have any moves here well
that's really funny yeah so so both
rooks just kind of tied down would you
be playing for a winger or this is just
a drop all that's a draw on black in
weights this I didn't see how
interesting yes so that was another
option
yeah but I think you played it very well
he play d4 so this e for move surprised
us given that the pawn seems a lot more
weak than it seems yeah
everything here is concrete because if I
of course it gives me some time I'll
just capture it but I have the problem
with the a file I guess that's a trigger
case a bit yeah tie down exactly so here
after Kendra so on
yes his idea is to play rook F a7 that's
the point
mm-hmm he wants to go there mm-hm so
Kevin I was just escaping and he looked
a guy said yes so he played he played
rook e1 King g6
well of course if I move my rook
somewhere to afford he just plays a five
and then it looks very dangerous and
then he goes to a seven so that's quite
unpleasant yeah I don't think I can
trade rooks if I play okay one he just
captures and then game probably is just
probably lost he goes in with a key with
keys
he is king 285 mm-hmm and it's just over
so I have to play after King g6 rook f1
back and he plays e3 so that's quite
interesting I actually don't know what
hope with major intent because I don't
really so the final position yes it to
rookies so it that's actually all of
them are only moves mm-hmm and here yeah
I thought you could just play a rock III
for instance instead of 45 so rookie
three yes saying I'm not sure what I'm
doing here well I probably I can I can
go for it I can probably play kimchi too
and he takes well I'm not sure about
dengue because I will have some counter
play I'll play I will capture and go
with the route 36 eventually here
however he has yes and over here he has
rook e8 after I take on e2 with my rook
grouped into three rock fe2 and okay I
ate keeping the Roxy yeah over here I
probably have to play with you three to
make some room for my king yeah that's
unclear I'm I was sure that I'm not
better but seems a bit scary though yeah
but I'm holding on so yeah I'm not sure
the angry means to be analyzed more
careful I actually don't have any time
yet
I'm sure you'll you'll probably analyze
it with smiies afterwards now did you
guys agree to a job before move for tea
structurally probably right after their
move Fortier he plays rookie 5-pin
offered me a draw
I see so directly on move for ya because
for sure I'm better here I cannot do
anything I cannot lick in t2
well I have to probably place you for
some flanger then go with my keen to d2
I don't think that I'm in huge trouble
but the position still looked unpleasant
to me so that's why I even didn't think
of rejection to the draw so I accepted
it right away yeah we saw a lot of games
finish either right after move 40 ever
before move for you today it seems like
the players wanna maybe take some rest
before going into the later stage of the
tournament
maybe I'm I was trying to play for a win
but I see it just didn't work out I see
do you know who you play tomorrow yes I
do actually I play it's hard to think
yeah yeah well we got graphics later but
for the the pairings tomorrow so Jen I
play what's up oh you're playing
monsters okay and do you have any
thoughts on that game well I'm playing
with black pieces so I'll be trying to
to make a drove but but we will see I'll
try to play fighting chess I mean no not
to lose a person and before you go I do
want to ask you about the tournament
overall is this your first time in st.
Louis no this is my second time actually
I see and what you think lost here
mm-hmm
what do you think about the overall
tournament conditions so far st. Louis
itself are you enjoying yourself yeah
but you said it many times that that's
problem my favorite tournament mm-hmm
the conditions are amazing everything
like the players are very strong so
that's perfect for playing chess well
that's great to hear it so I'll let you
get some rest and prepare and best of
luck in the rest of thank you so much
you're welcome
so we're gonna move on here and take a
look at and see if there's actually any
game still going scrolling through here
lots of drawers I believe the final game
still going was a battle between Peter
prohaszka and Renacci mabye of and I see
the game is not finished yet so we'll
stay with this one
and see how the game is progressing they
are after move 40 both
are are not in time trouble though Peter
is as perhaps getting in time trouble
again about to fall below ten minutes
kingi to is played and it seems like
white is finding some nice harmony with
the pieces given that I mean there's
really no breakthrough for for black in
the position I'm sure Knight f3 will be
played at some point and I see there was
a move played pawn g5 as black in this
position you want to create as many
complications as possible given that you
you know you're worse you just want to
try in and try and create some fire
hoping that your opponent could maybe
get confused and in some complications
I do like pawn g5 with idea that if the
knight potentially comes to f3 there
would be some resource pawn g4 but I'm
wondering if why can't just play Knight
a3 right away given that g4 and I take
t4 it just seems like white is scooping
up some pawns so I do want to welcome
back carrying them Silva welcome back
Catarina thank you that's right so we we
only have one game going any any
takeaways any thoughts on the day so far
I mean I think we saw interesting games
and Jeffrey's young again CRO share a
book I thought that was a very
interesting game I'm curious what's
gonna happen here I mean Peter has
nothing to lose I mean he can lose the
game but he has ten minutes you have to
just try for for whatever he can do here
that's right I always tell my students
that when you're in a losing position
don't give up try with with every last
resource that you have because yeah you
are expected to lose a game but you you
you want to create some hope for
yourself even if there's a very small
percentage chance that you'll you'll
save the game there's always that that
one maybe my new possibility that you
can that you can create a miracle yeah
and I think it's it's always hard to
play for the sided hassle advantage
because that's how it has to be careful
of not letting that idiot wanted to go
so I think Renaud still has to find the
precise moves to to gain the full point
so we'll let this game play out but
let's take a look at the standings for
group a after today of course the one
game still pending and we see
sifter Bailey on top of the leaderboard
if a thief has really been on fire this
tournament he has a great start he has
only a draw today he's going to win it
he's planning to win the tournament so
let's see who was gonna stop him
tomorrow
what is the pairing for tomorrow yeah we
have Benjamin back against received our
baliya it's probably probably going to
be our key matchup of the day going down
the list we have Peter Paris go against
Peru Janna Cobian euros Arabic against
vernaccia mabye of Sam 7 against Jeffrey
Zhang the two youngsters in the
tournament and then Daniel Friedman
against Alexander and is definitely some
exciting matchups to look forward to so
what about Group B and standings after
the round today we have camel dragons
still leading three and a half points
out of four I'm sorry out of five and we
have a tie for the second place where JJ
alum around a star game at Cinco Josh
free del Alejandro Ramirez and and race
to cop in all that three points and
let's take a look at the the matchups
for tomorrow and Group B we have
Daenerys O do a cassava against
Alejandro Ramirez Sergei Motte saenko
against andrey zhuk open camille dragon
against JJ ally morandi Tata of Abraham
Ian against Vladimir Bellis and Josh
Goodell against Robert Haga sorry on so
we have some exciting games tomorrow we
look forward to see you tomorrow also to
join us for the broadcast and I think
that's it today for Eric that's right
keep in mind you can watch all the
action on us chefs champs calm we'll be
back tomorrow at 3:30 Central Time the
game start at 1:00 p.m. Central time
looking forward to another exciting day
of chess see you tomorrow bye guys
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you